So today we're going to talk about how
to diagnose your liver from your foot
now we're not actually giving you an
actual diagnosis we're just using the
foot to look at indicators that you may
have a liver problem and I think one big
problem medicine is that everything is
so specialized you know you have just
one doctor that studies just the foot
and then you have another doctor that
just studies the liver a hepatologist
and sometimes if you just focus on one
area you're not looking at the big
picture and you might not be able to
associate different relationships So
today we're going to do that and the
more you understand about things like
this and the different associations the
more appreciation you're going to have
for your body especially your liver and
I think the better you're going to take
care of yourself I did another video on
this topic a while ago and I read one of
the comments that just prompted me to do
this updated video one lady mentioned
she drank a lot of alcohol and because
of that video she actually stopped
drinking so that's incredible so let's
Dive Right In and go to my whiteboard to
explain this next part all right let's
start with these purple brown red dots
on the lower part of the legs what's
going on here is we have leaky blood
vessels okay now there's a medical term
which I'm going to introduce you to okay
so it's a big word but I'll Define it
it's called
thrombocytopenia okay this condition
usually occurs with a liver problem all
right let's break it down what is a
thrombocyte well it's a platelet okay
what are platelets
they're cells that help clot okay in
fact the Greek word for thrombo means
clot and then cyto means cell and then
pinia means low so we have low platelets
so thrombocytopenia is basically you are
not going to be able to clot and so
you're going to have leaky blood vessels
and you're going to see this right here
now you do see this Advanced liver
disease and you also see it in diabetes
which by the way the liver can actually
create diabetes so you might see them in
both conditions all right the next thing
is spider angioma it's a spider-like
presentation of red blood vessels on
certain parts of your body and they can
show up in your ankles your foot your
lower legs other parts of the body this
is an estrogen problem because estrogen
dilates the blood vessels and that's why
you see this in pregnancy because
pregnant women are high in estrogen also
as a side effect from taking birth
control pills hormone replacement
therapy as well as in liver conditions
because the liver helps to buffer
estrogen and if there's damage in the
liver you're going to have higher levels
of estrogen in men and women all right
the next one is cracked heels so
sometimes you get this cracked dry
bleeding skin around your heels that's
usually a vitamin B3 deficiency now a B3
deficiency a real severe deficiency in
B3 would be pellegra but you can have a
subclinical pellagra which is not a
full-blown plega with all the different
symptoms but some of the symptoms which
involve the skin and so a B3 deficiency
affects areas of the body where you have
this higher rate of sell turnover like
the skin has to constantly replace
itself well when you're deficient in B3
now you're not going to be able to
replace these cells efficiently and it's
going to show up in cracked skin now
what can cause that well liver problems
which can come from drinking too much
alcohol it can also come from consuming
too much corn and I'll talk a little bit
about that in a bit okay so then we have
dry scaly skin so maybe a certain part
of your foot has this really roughened
dry scaly skin situation that's usually
low omega-3 fatty acids and that can
come from a lack of bile because let's
say part of the liver is fatty and it
can't produce the bile to extract these
fat soluble nutrients one being
omega-3 fatty acids now this can also be
from consuming too many
omega-6 fatty acids and that would be
like the corn oil the soy oil the canola
even peanut oil safflower sunflower oil
all right the next one is itchy skin
this usually is a condition where the
bile is backing up because there's some
type of sludge in the bile ducts and the
term for that is called choleostasis so
we're having this backup of bile that
backs up in the liver it backs up into
the blood and into the skin and if
there's bile in the skin you are going
to experience itchiness and many times
it's in the foot the bottom part of the
foot maybe this area of the foot right
through here you probably will also see
your urine is darker your skin might be
a bit on the yellow side especially the
whites of the eyes and your stool might
be on the lighter side as far as the
color and then we have bad odor I mean
one of the purposes of liver is to
detoxify the body and so if the liver
can't detoxify the toxins come out
through the skin I remember in practice
I learned a technique that really helped
people with low back pain by working on
their feet okay okay and so people would
come in and I'd be working on their feet
and different types of manipulation and
in massaging to the bottom of the foot
until some people came in with bad
livers I said after that you know I'm
going to refer these people out to work
on their feet because
some bad odor because certain people
even if they wash their feet on a
regular basis still will have this bad
odor if the liver is toxic
all right the other thing about the
bottom of the foot if the person has
pain numbness like a burning sensation
this is usually peripheral neuropathy
many times it's diagnosed as a plantar
fasciitis but here's the interesting
thing about that insulin resistance
which eventually turns into pre-diabetes
and then diabetes originates in the
liver so anyone with insulin resistance
pre-diabetes or diabetes is going to
have a liver problem and the more fat
and inflammation that the liver starts
to develop the more insulin resistance
they're going to have which aggravates
the condition aggravates the blood sugar
situation and then we have this thing
called gout now normally when you think
about gout you think of the kidney right
because the kidney filters the blood and
it's getting rid of this uric acid but
you have something called the urea cycle
okay which involves the breakdown of
protein and also involves uric acid and
so as you fix the liver and work on the
liver you're going to find your gout
attacks your gout symptoms are going to
be much better but the main gout symptom
is pain in this big toe and this joint
right through here there's inflammation
right there all right now we have
toenail fungus which usually is an
imbalance of microbes in your gut you
normally should have these Diversified
microbes to actually protect against the
overgrowth of fungus and so this is
associated with an imbalance in your
microflora and this is also associated
with the liver because the liver and the
bowel work very very closely and one of
the things that happens when the liver
is not working it's not able to produce
the bile that's supposed to keep the
small intestine clean of bacteria and
prevent an overgrowth so a healthy liver
can help prevent something called sibo
small intestinal bacterial overgrowth
and to keep these microbes in check so
you don't have this overgrowth of one
bacteria or a fungus versus another
alright the next thing you can have is
these corns on your toes usually they
grow on the inside of the toe it can be
very irritating and a corn is really a
vitamin A deficiency vitamin M A is
involved in the differentiation of
certain cells so anytime you're
deficient vitamin A you'll have all
sorts of skin issues maybe certain weird
growths that occur or dryness or
roughness so in addition to the omega-3
fatty acid deficiency you can also have
a vitamin A deficiency which comes from
the same thing low bile salts bile salts
help you break down the fat soluble
nutrients vitamin A d e k and a fatty
liver can prevent the production of bile
another symptom of a bad liver is when
your feet becomes very very hot so a
dysfunction with the liver will alter
the temperature of your feet and the
last symptom related to the liver is
this pitting edema so you press on your
lower leg and it leaves a little dent in
there that is a liver problem the liver
is normally supposed to make certain
proteins that keep this balance of fluid
in your body when you're deficient in
these proteins you start backing up with
fluids and it starts to show up in
between the cells it's called
interstitial spaces also in the spaces
around the abdomen usually you see this
with men who have cirrhosis they have
these like a pot belly there's fluid
inside it's called ascites or edema in
the lower part of your body usually in
your lower legs or feet which starts out
showing up more on the right side
because the liver is on the right side
and you have a lot of lymphatics that
can be backed up through that side if
you have a demon on both sides that
could affect the heart all right now
let's go back to my office all right
we're back and there's two things I want
to mention okay real simply we're going
to talk about what to avoid and then
what to do if you have a liver problem
okay so number one
um one of the biggest problems with
liver issues is taking a lot of
medications and of course I'm not going
to tell you to avoid your medications
but you might want to get with your
doctor to find some alternatives to
certain medications because if you're on
quite a few medications that is going to
create a lot of damage to the liver
because medications have toxic effects
and the liver is all about
detoxification so reducing the load is
going to be probably one of the most
important things all right number two
reducing the amount of sugar in refined
carbohydrates it's going to make a huge
change to your liver
the more sugar the more refined
carbohydrates the more fat you're going
to generate on your liver and I think
some people are not aware of the fact
that the cholesterol in their
bloodstream and the fat on their liver
most likely came from carbohydrates or
sugar and not the dietary fat or
cholesterol they're consuming so sugar
gets converted to cholesterol and fat in
the body there's a whole pathway that
does this and it ends up in your liver
all right number three the worse off
your liver is the less you need to
consume cooked Foods so if you're eating
all these cooked Foods you're basically
killing off the enzymes that the liver
needs to help with digestion foods that
can sit on the shelf life for a long
time are really hard on the liver all
right number four
this thing called alcohol okay alcohol
as you already know is a huge burden on
the liver and many other parts of the
body as well if you're drinking alcohol
for health reasons they've recently
found out that there is no health
benefits to alcohol your body has to
detoxify it alcohol creates a lot of
deficiencies especially vitamin B3 which
relates to a kind of a pellegral like
symptoms which is like dermatitis a lot
of skin issues not to mention B1
deficiencies magnesium deficiencies zinc
deficiencies all sorts of nutrient
deficiencies so if you can't completely
give up alcohol reduce it as much as you
can all right number five and this is
obvious you already know this junk food
fast food the food from fast food
restaurants are pretty deadly to the
liver of course I remember in college
living off different specials they had
at Burger King and McDonald's and uh I
paid the price and of course I Justified
it by saying I'll eat healthy when I
graduate and then when I graduated I
said I'll eat healthy when I get older
and that just kept going on and on all
right number six you want to avoid porn
okay now why am I saying corn because
there's something very specific about
corn corn has extremely low vitamin B3
and extremely low tryptophan that turns
into vitamin B3 and I already mentioned
this condition called pellegra which is
a vitamin B3 deficiency and you can also
have a subclinical pellagra type
situation where you're very very low in
vitamin B3 as well as tryptophan that
won't turn into B3 and you can have
various symptoms that relate to your
skin like dermatitis but also like
diarrhea and even dementia but it
creates all sorts of problems with your
like your heel cracking the skin being
very dry and Flaky and you might say
well well I don't really consume any
corn do you realize the average person
in America consumes 1
540 pounds or 700 kilograms of corn
every single year now to be totally
transparent I think some of that
consumption and I'm not 100 sure could
include ethanol like buying ethanol in
your gasoline so I'm not exactly sure if
it's 1500 pounds I mean it could be a
lot less but it's definitely at least
350 pounds but we have corn flour in
different products I mean there's
literally hundreds of foods that have
corn in them grits corn chips high
fructose corn syrup kids are just
drinking tons of corn a certain
alcoholic beverages are made from corn
you have corn oil that's in a lot of
different foods as well as your salad
dressing
maltodextrin which is a synthetic sugar
is you usually from corn you have
popcorn you have dextrose which is
another synthetic sugar which is on a
lot of different foods modified corn
starch and then you also have 60 percent
of the feeds to livestock are made from
corn I'm talking about the beef Pig
chicken okay so all this corn goes into
the animal and you're basically eating
corn indirectly so like I said before
corn can create a B3 deficiency and a
tryptophan deficiency if you're not also
consuming other things that are high in
B3 and tryptophan like animal products
eggs dairy
Etc all right so let's talk about what's
good for the liver okay well if you have
any problem with the gallbladder you
need something called Tad cut okay Tad
cut is a type of bile salt that is
wonderful for the liver it'll help to
thin the bile and drain all the the
pipes of the liver and allow toxins to
freely float through these little pipes
into your small intestine number two one
of the best herbs actually the best
herbs
actually the best herb for the liver is
milk thistle okay and you might even
have it in your backyard but milk
thistle has special properties to
protect the liver it's used if someone
has some type of poisoning either from a
mushroom or maybe a snake or maybe
medication in fact if you do take
medications you should at the same time
be taking milk thistle to protect the
liver and milk thistle as well as that
tatka can help reduce fat on your liver
and number three we have can start
consuming more cruciferous vegetables
the kale the broccoli the Brussels
sprouts the cabbage
those vegetables are high in Sulfur
which are really important in the
detoxification process of the liver as
well as the detoxification of excess
amount of estrogen that builds up in the
liver all right number four fasting and
I'm talking regular
daily fasting like if you can do one
meal a day that would be awesome because
the more fasting you can do the more
good you're going to do for your liver
at the very minimum do two meals no
snacks all right number five healthy
keto doing the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet using high quality foods
that will greatly take the stress off
the liver you can actually decrease the
fat off the liver even within two weeks
of doing the ketogenic diet wow you just
have something very effective to do with
that liver and number six cod liver oil
what's unique about cod liver oil is
that it's high in omega-3 fatty acids
which is going to help the fat on the
liver to reduce inflammation help break
down scar tissue of the liver but also
you have vitamin A and vitamin D which
is also great for your skin and some of
the other symptoms that you might have
on your foot now a really important next
video for you to watch would be the best
seven foods to clean out your liver and
this gives you much better detail on
what you need to be eating and I put
that video right here check it out